well i was making the point that
deprivation exists right across our
country and needs to be addressed and
that's why we need to make sure our
funding formulas recognize that and
people who need help and extra
investment aren't just limited to big
urban areas you find them in towns
across the united kingdom and in rural
areas too and that was a point i was
making that our funding formulas that
failed to recognize that are out of date
and they needed changing that's work
that i started doing as local government
minister and i'm actually pleased as
chief secretary and chancellor to have
been able to change the rules of the
treasury to make sure that we get
investment in all our regions and to
create things like the leveling up fund
which puts investment in communities
across the country
isn't this a case of pitting different
parts of the country against each other
exactly what you accused lis truss's
campaign of doing earlier in the week
with her policy on public sector pay no
it's about making sure that government
funding goes to the places where need is
highest and it's right that those
funding formulas are accurate that they
actually look at the need in different
areas measure that properly and reflect
how things have changed from the past
and i think that's an entirely sensible
thing to be doing because it's not just
big urban areas that require that extra
investment it's also people in rural
communities it's also people in towns
and that's what we've done both as a
government in the past what i want to do
as prime minister in the future level up
across the country so that no matter
where people live they feel incredible
opportunities and pride in the place
that they call home
on the economy the institute of fiscal
studies says you both need to start
talking about the extra support you'll
need to give people on low incomes
what targeted support will you offer do
you accept you'll need to do more and
quickly well what the institute of
physical studies also said is that the
priority right now has got to be to
tackle inflation and that's my priority
now we heard from the bank of england
yesterday clearly the economy faces
challenges the rights are flashing red
and the root cause of that is inflation
and i want to grip inflation not fuel it
and make it worse and plans that pump
tens of billions of pounds of borrowed
money into the economy at a time of
already rising inflation risk doing
exactly that making prices go higher
last longer push up mortgage rates
that's not my plan i want to grip
inflation help people with the cost of
living grow the economy and cut their
taxes
with impending recession liz trust says
quote business as usual end quote with
help no one are you offering anything to
try and stop it
well actually what i announced as
chancellor was significant support to
help particularly the most vulnerable
families in our country get through the
autumn and winter that's worth around 1
200 pounds in total but now that we know
bills are going to be higher than they
were when we did that it's right that we
go further as prime minister i want to
cut vat on energy bills this autumn and
as people have seen from me over the
past couple of years i always stand
ready to help the british economy and
families through difficult times they
can trust me to do that because they've
seen me do it before